CARRIE LAURENO:
Welcome to Google,
for those of us who
are visiting today.
My name is Carrie Laurena.
I am the founder of the
Google Veterans Network
and head up our veteran
outreach strategy here.
Happy early Veterans Day
to everyone in the room.
I feel like we're
among family today.
I see so many familiar faces,
both people who work here
at Google, many of our
non-profit partners,
distinguished guests
from the military.
Thank you all for
being here today
in celebration of Veterans
Day and to help us here
at Google celebrate
the way we wanted to,
which is working towards
our goal of bridging
the civil military divide.
The reason that
we're here today is
to celebrate an exhibit
that opened on Friday
at the 9/11 Memorial Museum that
is called The Call to Serve,
recognizing the extraordinary
service of our military
in the immediate wake
of the 9/11 attacks.
After over a decade
of war and, everything
that happened in Iraq, the
immediate accomplishments
of our military, frankly,
were overshadowed,
and there were so
many early successes
that are not brought
to the light of day.
And we wanted to help bring
those stories to life,
and to recognize
those individuals who
made really truly extraordinary
achievements and contributions
on behalf of all of us
who have not served.
We were fortunate
enough to brainstorm
about this idea with Michael
Frazier, our friend and partner
at the 9/11 Museum,
the Executive Vice
President of Communications
and Marketing.
Where are you, Michael?
In the back, of course.
So Michael I had a conversation
a couple months ago.
And we said, this is this
incredibly beautiful museum
that had just opened in May.
What could we do in
advance of Veterans Day
to support the 9/11
Museum in their mission
to recognize the overwhelming
number of acts of compassion
in the wake of 9/11, which
is part of their mission?
And we happen to have
some technology that
helps people tell stories.
We launched it last year.
It's called Google Tour
Builder, and it enables anyone
out there, any
aspiring storyteller,
to drop a pin on a map,
add a little bit of copy
to that, up to 25 photos
and videos in one place,
pull it all together in a
beautiful storytelling format.
And I like to joke that we built
this so that my mom could do it
without any assistance
for me whatsoever.
It's really that easy
for any storyteller
to go in and talk
about their journey.
And who has better stories
to tell than the military?
The most incredible
achievements in the most amazing
far off places that most of us
never have a chance to visit.
And what if we
could work together,
the 9/11 Museum and Google, to
bring those stories to life,
to bring them to museum,
and to bring them
into the public
eye at a time when
the public is tiring of the war.
And there are a lot
of other stories
that are out there
about service members.
What if we can convince-- coerce
in the most positive way--
some of our most humble service
members, who truly have done
amazing things, to share their
stories in a way that might
inspire other service
members to do the same.
I've learned an important
lesson from a friend and partner
of ours.
Colonel Jim Eisenhower, who is
at the Joint Chiefs of Staff
and runs the reintegration
office for that team,
has taught me a lesson
that service members
return to communities.
And we want communities
to be a place that
are welcoming to our service
members and their families
so that as they face
those difficult chapters
of transition that
are ahead of them,
that there's greater
awareness and understanding
about those issues, and
that service members feel
good about going
home and are embraced
by the people who
do care about them
the most in very
practical, tangible ways.
So we're going to talk a little
bit about all that today.
We're going to share with
you some of the exhibit here,
encourage all of you
go down to the museum
this week during Veterans
Week to see it before Friday.
And if you haven't
been able to see it,
you can check it out online at
911memorial.org/calltoserve.
That will be there
in perpetuity,
and a wonderful tribute
to the gentlemen
that you're going to
meet in a few minutes.
So without further ado, I'd
like to invite all of our guests
onstage to join us.
Ladies and gentlemen, please
meet your storytellers
and these incredible
service members.
[APPLAUSE]
So from the look of it, I
was asking Colonel Collins
if there were any women who
served in Afghanistan in 2001.
And the answer's probably no.
But I'm here to represent
all the women that
followed in their footsteps.
So I'd like to start
with introductions.
We have a large
group of people here.
Everybody has a unique story.
I know these gentlemen
extremely well at this point,
having worked with
them, and my team
having worked with them
to develop these stories.
But they didn't know each
other until last night.
And to bring a [INAUDIBLE]
together with a West Point
professor together with a
Marine Recon professional
and several Special
Forces guys was
a really interesting
experience last night.
And in the spirit
of diversity, this
is your United
States military here.
So let's start with
Brandon Brewer.
I'm going to quickly
do introductions.
Brandon was a US Coast Guard
veteran in the Public Affairs
office.
He was on duty a few blocks
from the World Trade Center
and witnessed the attacks
and the Maritime evacuation
of the city.
He shot aerial photographs of
Ground Zero and the Homeland
Security efforts underway
there for several weeks,
retired from the
Coast Guard in 2012,
and was telling me last
night how much he missed it.
So we'll ask you why you
miss it a little bit later.
Next I'd like to introduce you
to Joe Quinn, US Army veteran.
Joe is the Northeast
Regional Director
for Team Red,
White & Blue, which
we are proud to be a partner
of this wonderful veterans'
service organization here in
New York and around the country.
Joe was finishing his last
year at West Point when
Flight 11 crashed
into the North Tower,
killing his brother James, who
worked at Cantor Fitzgerald.
And prior to working with
Team Red, White & Blue,
he was an associate at the
Combating Terrorism Center,
an instructor in the Department
of Social Sciences at the US
Military Academy at West Point.
He also worked in Afghanistan
in counterinsurgency work.
He spent six years in the
Army, two deployments in Iraq,
and received his Master's
degree in Public Policy
from the Kennedy School.
Lieutenant Colonel Eric
Dill, US Marine Corps.
Happy birthday, sir.
For those who don't know, today
is-- where are the Marines?
Excellent.
Lieutenant Colonel
Dill was conducting
training in Australia on 9/11.
His unit immediately
deployed to prepare
for the invasion of Afghanistan.
They were part of the
first conventional force
to enter the country, seizing
Kandahar International Airport.
He began his military career
enlisting in the Marine Corps
in February of 1993,
attended Texas Tech,
went on to be commissioned
as a Second Lieutenant,
and had multiple,
multiple assignments.
His service included
three deployments
to Iraq, two deployments
to Afghanistan,
multiple deployments to Africa.
Mr. Mark Nutch.
Mark Nutch is a US
Army Special Forces
veteran from
Leavenworth, Kansas.
Thanks for making
the trip here today.
Mark is the former Commander
of Operational Detachment 595,
one of the very first units
to insert into Afghanistan
to wrest Mazar-i-Sharif from the
Taliban and Al Qaeda fighters.
ODA 595 is also known
as the Horse Soldiers,
for those of you who've
heard about that group
of extraordinary men.
Mark retired from the
Army and continues
to do contract work
in Afghanistan,
and he is working on a
book about his experiences.
He wants to write it himself
from his perspective,
along with his teammates.
And that's something
that we're really
excited to read
when it comes out.
Scotty Neal, US Army
Special Forces veteran,
Director of Strategic
Development for the Green Beret
Foundation from Tampa, Florida.
Scott was in a Green
Beret training exercise
when the towers fell.
He immediately
deployed to Afghanistan
with the objective of destroying
Al Qaeda training camps.
He spent 25 years in
the Army Special Forces
with multiple combat tours
in 5th Special Forces Group,
and he was later a
Senior Enlisted Advisor
to the Director of the US
Special Operations Command's
Interagency Task Force at
MacDell Air Force Base.
Thank you.
Lieutenant Colonel Liam Collins,
also US Army Special Forces,
is the Director of Defense
and Strategic Studies
program at US Military Academy
at West Point, our neighbor.
Lieutenant Colonel Collins
was conducting an interagency
exercise in Hungary
when the towers fell.
Less than a month later,
he deployed to Afghanistan
to hunt Taliban and
Al Qaeda targets.
For his second operation, he
parachuted in from 18,000 feet.
He is a career
Special Forces officer
who has served in a variety of
special operations assignments,
combat operations in
Afghanistan, Iraq,
multiple deployments to
Bosnia, Africa, South America.
He holds a Bachelor of Science
degree in Aerospace Engineering
from West Point, a Master in
Public Affairs from Princeton
University, my alma mater,
Woodrow Wilson School
of Public International Affairs,
and a doctorate from Princeton
as well.
His research centers on military
innovation during times of war.
And last but not least,
last but not least,
Master Sergeant Eric Stubner.
US Army Ranger, First
Battalion 75th Ranger Regiment
from El Paso, Texas,
originally from North Dakota.
Master Sergeant Stubner
had a boyhood dream
of becoming a ranger,
and he pursued this.
He deployed to
Afghanistan in support
of Operation Anaconda, which
you'll hear more about.
In all he completed 10
post-9/11 combat tours,
six in Iraq and
four in Afghanistan.
And he will retire from the
Army in a couple of weeks,
November 26.
Here comes the
embarrassing part.
Sergeant Stubner was awarded
the Silver Star Medal
for conspicuous
gallantry and intrepidity
in action while serving
as a squad leader
during combat
operations in support
of and in this operation that
I mentioned called Anaconda.
And it's something that
I'm excited for you all
to hear about and to know
about what happened there
and the actions that he took.
So quite an amazing group
of people on this panel.
Brandon, I'd love to start
with you and your journey.
Tell us more about
where you were on 9/11
and where that took you
in terms of your service.
BRANDON BREWER: OK.
Well, I wasn't with
Yogi Berra, but I
figured if I'm going to talk
to people in New York, what
better New Yorker
to have next to me.
I had a picture
with Scooter, too,
so I had to flip a coin to
see if it was Yogi or Scooter.
Like you said, I was on duty
here in New York during 9/11.
If you've seen the tiny
little three-story building
on one side of Battery
Park up against the water,
that's the Coast Guard
building here in the city.
And that's where I
was that morning.
And I guess I can
kind of run through
a little quick chronology.
I'm a little bit of a talker.
Where's my wife?
She knows this.
She's a listener.
I'm a talker.
Like a lot of people
that were here that day,
we didn't really know what
was going on at first.
And I was there at the
Battery, and a co-worker
let us know that something
happened, that a plane had hit
the North Tower the
World Trade Center.
And I think a lot of people
thought this was just
some kind of an accident, maybe
somebody had a small plane
and they went off course,
and it was just a very tragic
accident.
And we quickly knew that it
wasn't when the second plane
hit, and so many people
then knew what happened.
So as the day went on-- that's
Battery Park right there
on the screen, on the
earth side of the screen.
So being in the city
and staying in the city
throughout that
chaotic day, we still
didn't fully realize
the significance
of what we were witnessing.
And if you look at the photos
that are scrolling through
right there, you can see
a lot of the folks that
were trying to
evacuate the city.
And this was happening
all around us.
And what we didn't know-- we
knew that the Coast Guard was
helping to coordinate
the maritime component
of the evacuation, but
what we didn't know
was that in the course
of about eight hours,
a half million people
would be evacuated
by water, which is a
very amazing story.
It's the biggest
maritime evacuation
in the history of the world.
So that was a part of what we
were seeing going on around us.
CARRIE LAURENO: Joe?
JOE QUINN: So I
was a Senior, what
they call a first [INAUDIBLE]
at the United States Military
Academy at West
point at the time.
I feel bad.
We did an earlier version
of this at the 9/11 museum,
and you hear a lot of the
same bad jokes coming at you.
CARRIE LAURENO: Everybody here
was working earlier today.
Not the same crowd.
They're still good jokes.
JOE QUINN: OK.
Good.
No, but I was an English
major at West Point,
which is kind of odd.
It's kind of an oxymoron.
Yeah, and I'm also
from Brooklyn,
which kind of adds to it.
And the joke is that Walt
Whitman is also from Brooklyn,
so take that.
So yeah, I was in a Native
American Literature class.
And then, kind of the
thing at West Point,
if you've ever been there,
it's like mice in a maze,
like everything's on clockwork.
There's no spare time.
And I remember leaving
class that day,
and there was something
off about kind
of the movements of the cadets.
And then I found myself
back to my barracks room,
where I was going
to hit the rack.
That's what cadets do on
their down time, they sleep.
Colonel Collins knows
this pretty well.
And getting there, my roommate
saying, turn on the television.
And television was
actually something new
at West Point at the time.
And we had these
huge giant computers
that looked-- they were
the size of microwaves.
Maybe something new to
younger Googlers here,
these old laptops.
I remember clicking
and then seeing
what everyone else was
kind of seeing at the time,
just seeing the
Twin Towers on fire.
And it really
didn't look that bad
from the size of the towers.
That was my initial reaction.
And talking to my mother later,
she would say-- her first words
out of her mouth was, oh
my goodness, we're at war
and my son's at West Point,
never really imagining
the unfathomable, was
that my brother Jimmy
worked in the North Tower
of the World Trade Center.
He worked for a company called
Cantor Fitzgerald, which
lost all 658 of their employees.
So I remember trying to get
out of West Point-- I finally
got out of West
Point the next day--
and going down to the
scene and just seeing
absolute destruction.
I was telling Eric before
that I'd never saw destruction
that you looked up at
and not kind of down at.
And then eventually making my
way back to my childhood home
in Marine Park, Brooklyn,
which was a neighborhood that
was a lot of firemen.
I mean, that was your choice.
You were either a cop, fireman,
or if you were good at math
you went to Wall Street.
Which my brother
was terrible at math
but he was good at
bullshit, and so that's
how he got to Cantor Fitzgerald.
But no, and then my world was
obviously turned upside down.
But you know, one of the
things-- obviously this
is kind of a personal
nature, but I think
everyone's world
changed, especially
everyone that I'm privileged
to be up here with.
So afterwards, with help
from a lot of understanding
professors, I
graduated West Point.
And then within a
year and a half later,
I was in Iraq in 2003.
And it was just--
it was incredible.
What I didn't tell
you, I was also
recruited to play basketball at
West Point, which you probably
can obviously tell
by my physique.
And I remember there's
just so many moments.
We were started in
Fallujah, then Ramadi,
and then hit-- and
then just kind of went
through Western Anbar
with the 3rd ACR, and just
rebuilding and moving on.
And then I remember
just one of my soldiers
saying-- you know, it was
just an incredible experience
being a 21-year-old
kid at West Point,
and then all of a sudden a year
later, here you are in Iraq.
So that was kind of my
initial foray into combat.
CARRIE LAURENO: Thank you.
Colonel Dill?
ERIC DILL: OK.
So I was in Darwin, Australia
when 9/11-- it was actually
September 12, being on the other
side of the International Date
Line.
What I was doing there, I was
part of a 3,000-man Marine unit
that was actually
forward deployed,
had been training for the past
year to respond to a crisis
contingency type situation.
Generally, Marine
expeditionary units,
when they're called up
to respond to a crisis
or contingency, it's usually
there's unrest in a country,
so they're evacuating an embassy
or something small scale,
or a humanitarian assistance,
disaster response situation
like a natural disaster
type situation.
But in this situation, we
went from being prepared
for something like that to going
into Afghanistan, which we were
also prepared for
conventional operations.
But we had just finished
a week of training.
We had been deployed about
a month at that point.
And so we were on
the town that night,
getting ready-- we were
going to leave the next day,
so we had a night of liberty.
And we tried to go
into this one place.
I'd been on the
compound with the guys
that we'd been training
with for the week.
And they didn't have-- they
only had Australian rules
football on the TV.
So as the news was coming in
we were kind of unaware of it.
And we went out on the town.
And we tried to
get into one place,
and they told us no, the World
Trade Center had been bombed
was the word they used.
And it didn't sound plausible.
So we tried going in next door.
We had actually been in
the place next door before
and it was a pretty
hopping place.
And it was completely different
when we went in this time.
There's a picture
of it right there.
But it was a totally
different vibe.
Everyone was kind of crowded
around these TV screens,
these big screens.
And I couldn't see
what was on the screen
because there was a
crowd in front of them,
but I think the word I used this
morning is a hollow feeling,
just because the way everyone
was looking at the screen,
I got that as I walked
in and I saw that.
And as I made my way closer--
you know, you get close enough,
you start to be able
see through the people.
And once I got close enough
where I could actually
see the screens, the first
image I saw were the towers,
and they were still
smoking at that point.
And I turned to my
friend and said,
I think we need to
go back to the ship.
And everything
changed after that.
And I was in Pakistan a month
later and Afghanistan a month
after that.
CARRIE LAURENO: And what
were you doing in Pakistan?
Was the object of
going-- most people think
that you would go
directly to Afghanistan.
Why Pakistan?
ERIC DILL: Well,
what we had to do
is we had to establish some
forward bases in Pakistan.
And one of them was
at Jacobabad Airfield.
There were a couple others.
And it was at that
time allowing--
they were what we called
lily pads to enable forces
to build up in a somewhat benign
environment like Pakistan,
and then be able to move
into Afghanistan from there.
Also what they were
doing was it was a place
for fighters to divert that
were having emergencies.
It was also a place for
some of the soft forces that
went in initially,
like especially
early to launch from there.
I think maybe Liam
will get into that.
I watched in jealousy
one night as the Rangers
and some other forces
refueled at Jacobabad
to go in and hit
Mullah Omar's house,
the leader of the Taliban.
So anyway-- that
answer your question?
CARRIE LAURENO: Absolutely.
Mark?
MARK NUTCH: On 9/11, just
a few days before that,
I had completed two years
of my typical assignment
as a Special Forces Captain in
a Detachment Commander role.
And we had deployed a lot
throughout the Middle East
and Central Asia.
Prior to 9/11 my team
had spent a great deal
of months in Uzbekistan
working with the Uzbek Special
Forces, which is a typical
mission that our Special Forces
conducts working with
coalition partners
and such around the world.
But these guys were already
at war, and this is in 2000,
and they were fighting against
Al Qaeda-based affiliates
in the Central Asian states,
Kazakhstan, Uzbekistan,
Kyrgyzstan, and that area.
On 9/11, my wife was
seven months pregnant
and I happened to be home
that morning with her.
We had an OB
appointment, and we were
getting ready to go to that.
And so we saw what was
happening on the television,
and had a couple young boys
at home, then three and four.
And they're seeing
the television
before we realized
what was going on
and got turned in their room.
But they were already
asking questions
over the next few days
of why did somebody
fly these planes
into these buildings?
And to explain to
your sons-- they
knew we were in Special
Forces and what we do.
And just said, hey, Dad has got
to go, go find some bad guys.
It was an emotional day, an
emotional time to do that.
And then over the next few
days, as I got into work, then
was notified a couple
days later that I
was going to be put
right back on my team,
and that our team had been
picked out of the Fifth Special
Forces Group to be one
of the first deployed.
And we didn't really know what
our mission was going to be yet
except that we were going to a
then-undisclosed location which
turned out to be in
Uzbekistan, another one
of these early staging
basis like Colonel Dillon
and his guys set up in Pakistan.
But that would become our
Special Operations task force
staging base.
And that's kind of how
9/11 unfolded for me.
CARRIE LAURENO: Scotty?
SCOTTY NEAL: All right.
I get the microphone now.
No, actually 9/11-- and
Mark sort of knows it
because it was actually his
team that was escorting us.
We were in a training
exercise getting
ready to go into the
Middle East 1 October,
and we were part of
an element called
the Commanders In Extremis Force
that the Regional Combatant
Commander could use to
deploy at any time in case
there was some
immediacy in there.
So we thought that
it was actually
part of the training exercise.
I remember very
vividly sitting there.
Because when you're in isolation
you're just fed information.
Your partner team controls
anything coming in and out.
That way you don't have
outside influences,
and you're focused on this
simulated terrorist attack,
which at the time
we thought was what
was going on, because he walked
in and he wrote on the board
that the World Trade
Center had been hit.
And it wasn't really until
about four or five hours
later when everything
came together
and they said no, this
is really happening.
So we were pretty much ready
to go anyways into the area.
But initially we
deployed into Kuwait,
where we already had an
initial presence there.
And then I was sent immediately
to the Embassy of Yemen
to work with other
agency partners
to determine-- there was this
big initial outpour from all
the other countries,
and they obviously
started wondering what they
could do to support our efforts
and really to get into this.
So everybody was
lining up and wanting
to support the American effort.
And then from there,
just like everybody else,
we went to another
location, a small island,
and we prepared to
go into Kandahar.
So what you're seeing
now is another task force
called Task Force K-Bar, which
was led by a SEAL at the time.
But it was all the
other countries' efforts
of special operators that
came together in one location.
So you had the English,
Australians, New Zealanders,
the Dutch, just a whole
mixture, the SEALS.
And all of us would
come together.
And at that time the
unconventional forces
had really routed the
Taliban and their leadership,
and they were so fractured,
which made them vulnerable.
And we used that opportunity to
really take those battlefield
leaders off the battlefield.
CARRIE LAURENO: Colonel Collins.
LIAM COLLINS: All right.
So on 9/11 I was in
Budapest, Hungary
as part of an
interagency exercise
that we were working over there.
I remember somebody
walking in the room--
and this is prior to having
satellite TV everywhere,
so we didn't have TV
screens all over the wall--
and somebody said the tower
had been hit by an airplane.
Just thought it was maybe one
of these small little commuter
aircraft or something
that hit it.
And about 20 or
30 minutes later,
when everybody came back in
and told us the second one hit,
we kind of knew
that at that point
it was a terrorist
attack, because I've
been focused on counterterrorism
since probably about '98, '99.
So that pretty much ended
the exercise for us.
I was the only one from my
unit that was on this exercise.
So I was wanting
to get back home
because I knew were going
to be deploying soon.
When I went to sleep that night,
I thought on it a little bit,
and I kind of believed that
it would be a long war.
I wasn't even married
or had kids yet,
but I figured it's going
to be a war that they're
going to be fighting
as they grew up.
So I figured it was going
to be a decades-long war.
So quickly got
back to Fort Bragg,
and there was no intelligence,
so it took awhile
to kind of actually
get over there.
We finally got over there and
into Afghanistan the first time
in September, mid-
to early September.
Didn't know Eric, but I
probably ran into Eric
without knowing it at
an airfield somewhere.
I guess his security guys
let him put more on here
than mine put on here.
So good for him.
I can actually pick
out points on a map.
But that's what they let
me put out there sometimes.
So they may not be
the right place,
but they're the right country.
And then we came out
of the first time
and then went back in
November the second time.
And the second time we went
back in, earlier in the month
i remember talking to one of
our intelligence analysts,
asking him how long he
thought the Taliban would
fall in Kabul.
And he's like, yeah,
probably take a year or two,
looking at how long it
took the Russians to do it.
And then two days later, then
Kabul had kind of fallen.
And so that night our
Commanding General
asked us if we could get
into Afghanistan the next day
to watch the highway
basically going between Kabul
and Kandahar, and told
him yeah, we can get in,
but we're going to
have to jump in.
That's the only way
we can get in safely.
And so he said, go
ahead and do it.
So then that's how we
went back into Afghanistan
the second time.
CARRIE LAURENO:
Sergeant Stubner.
ERIC STUBNER: On 9/11,
the night before we
had a training exercise.
We train pretty
late into the night,
so they usually give
us a little earlier
work call the next morning.
So I woke up, was going
into work later than usual.
Got in the shower, turned
the shower radio on.
So yes, actually, when 9/11
came I was caught with my pants
down.
But I heard it on the radio.
I didn't really believe it.
I thought it was some talk
show gimmick, something
on the radio.
Got my roommate's
attention, came in,
told him to go turn the TV on.
It was kind of an
impact to me because we
were in what we call
Ready Force One status.
It's from when the
first call's made,
we had two hours to be
into work, ready to go,
wherever-- and they claim
we could be anywhere
in the world, boots on
the ground, in 18 hours.
So that I was really my
chance that we were going.
Headed into work,
traffic wasn't too bad
until I got closer to post.
And it was endless to try
to even get onto post.
Parked my car,
literally ran onto post,
ran to work because I wanted to
get there as fast as I could,
and thought we were
going to deploy.
We never did, which
seemed odd to me.
Eventually they ended up
taking 3rd Ranger Battalion out
of Fort Benning,
and they did a jump
into Objective Rhino,
Kandahar Airfield.
And I thought I
was actually going
to miss out on my chance
to be able to go to war.
And everyone up here,
you do something,
you train, it be doing things
at Google and you never
get to actually do anything on
the website or apply into it.
Thought I was going
to miss my chance.
And then rumors
started coming around
that we were going to
get to go to Afghanistan.
Had a few failed
attempts trying to leave
due to aircraft problems.
But I did eventually
end up making my way
to Bagram Airfield on
New Year's Eve of 2001.
So I got to wake
up to the new year
in Bagram Airfield in 2002.
CARRIE LAURENO: Let's talk
a little bit about what
happened there, and specifically
the Battle of Roberts Ridge.
ERIC STUBNER: We spent
our time training,
did a lot of training.
Rangers, they
train, train, train.
We're not DSF guys.
We're not that cool.
CARRIE LAURENO: SF
guys don't train?
You don't have to.
ERIC STUBNER: They work out.
LIAM COLLINS: They train.
CARRIE LAURENO: They train.
Liam-- sorry, Colonel
Collins, rumor
has it that you can
run a six-minute mile.
Is that true?
LIAM COLLINS: For 26.2 miles.
CARRIE LAURENO: OK.
So we've established that
they work out and they train.
But you were training that day.
ERIC STUBNER: We trained a lot.
We'd go here and there.
We went to Kandahar to train.
We were basically
staged in Bagram.
250 soldiers started out
there, little small compound,
few tents.
Our main mission was to be a
QRF, or a Quick Reaction Force,
or 911 to whatever
kind would happen.
In Afghanistan we'd been
called out on a few things.
And one night--I think it was
our night we were allotted
for the showers-- we had a
blocked time to take showers.
And--
CARRIE LAURENO:
Once a week, right?
ERIC STUBNER: Yeah, once a week.
In the middle of the night
we'd have to wake up.
So everyone kind of woke up
to shower and went there.
The pipes were frozen, couldn't
get our shower for the week.
It was fun.
Heard a rumor something
was going to-- there
was a mission coming.
Our standard was
to, when we were
told, 10 minutes on the
vehicles, ready to go.
That wasn't going that fast.
Seemed like kind
of a slower night.
Eventually made our way
down to the airfield.
Heard there was a Navy
SEAL that fell off
a helicopter in the vicinity
of an airfield in Khost.
So it seemed pretty easy.
Hearing reports, they had
him on the ISR watching him.
There were some
people around him.
Was he already rescued?
Not.
A lot of broken
miscommunication.
And we were ready to
load two helicopters.
We were told only
one was going to go.
Don't always get answers why.
Got back on the
vehicles, ready to go,
and they gave us the
second aircraft to go in.
So we took off, flew
around for awhile.
It's hard to hear.
Back in the early part of
the deployments, I guess,
you didn't have the
communication pieces to hear.
It was loud.
And didn't really know what
was going on, to be honest.
And we were flown back to
Gardez and we touched down.
Didn't really know,
again, what was going on.
And then we were told that
we were going to be going in.
They located where the SEAL was.
We were flying in,
and on our way in,
the news we got, or I got,
we got on the aircraft,
was our first helicopter
had gone down.
There were three
killed in action right
from the start of it.
And told us we were
going into a hot LZ.
Flew in, helicopter
sort of touched down.
Immediately got off the
helicopter in waist-deep snow.
And the helicopter
flew away, and there
wasn't a single shot fired.
It was like, felt kind of lost.
You were expecting to
get shot at right away,
and there was nothing.
But then as you looked
up the mountain,
you could see jets coming
in and doing gun runs
on the top of the mountain.
And we were told we were set
in an offset location, which
was about 2000 feet below
the peak of 10,500 feet
and a straight line
distance of 700 meters.
So it was a fun 2
and 1/2 hour climb
to get to the top
of the mountain.
CARRIE LAURENO: In
waist-deep snow.
ERIC STUBNER: Some
And once we got up there,
there wasn't really
time for a break
because the perimeter,
the area wasn't secured yet.
And we immediately
organized SALT teams
to take out some bunkers
and a little trench
line that was up there.
And then it succeeded into
moving casualties from the day.
There were seven killed
in action that day,
and I think six wounded.
I'm having a brain cramp now.
Don't quote me.
Don't Google it.
And we were up there
for a total of 18 hours.
And eventually that
night, once they
deemed it was safe enough
to bring other aircraft in,
they brought the aircraft
in and let us [INAUDIBLE]
from the mountain from that day.
CARRIE LAURENO: And
you're being quite humble
about your actions
taken that day.
If I remember from reading
correctly from your tour
that you carried 12 service
members up the mountain.
Is that correct?
And one of those was your best
friend, Sergeant [? Kroes ?].
Tell us about
Sergeant [? Kroes ?].
ERIC STUBNER: He was-- I treated
him pretty much like a brother.
His mom blessed
me as her son now.
I'm the closest thing she
has left to him from there.
I kind of talked
about it earlier.
Joe laughed at it.
I did a lot with him.
Went to his house
for Thanksgiving.
Really a neat family.
Brad was really a
super neat individual.
First time I met his mom, I went
to his house for Thanksgiving.
Three of us went.
She called and spoke
to us before we went.
She's like, OK,
when you come I want
you to feel like you're at home.
Tell me three things you had
at Thanksgiving growing up.
I told her three things.
So did the other two guys.
When we actually showed
up at Thanksgiving,
in addition to
everything she made,
there were nine other
dishes, three for each of us.
Christmas, I didn't do anything
with him for Christmas.
He came back from Jacksonville
and he walked in my room
one night, and he's
like, hey, tell
my mom thanks for the stocking.
OK, get on the phone,
I'm like, hey, Sheila,
thanks for the stocking.
She's like, did you like it?
I was like, yeah, I did.
The next day Brad
gave me the stocking.
That's the only grudge
I have against him.
In it there were $50 gift cards
to Carrabba's, calling cards.
It was probably a $400
stocking, and I was like, Brad,
I didn't know.
And he goes, no, it
was just a stocking.
Ended up taking him home to
North Dakota after Christmas
because we had our
block leave then.
Drove into North Dakota,
had a mishap on the road.
The car ended up
flipping end over end
upon entering North Dakota.
And of course both of us were
driving with no shoes on.
So from him being
from Florida, I
was like, welcome
to North Dakota.
Every window was
knocked out of the car.
We both jumped out.
Nothing but socks.
And had a few moments with Brad,
as everyone in the military
does some sort of bond or blend
with a friend, a colleague,
whatever.
CARRIE LAURENO: Mark, your team
is known as the Horse Soldiers.
Can you tell us why?
And can you tell us about
the very special statue
that's down by
the 9/11 Memorial?
MARK NUTCH: Yeah, my
Special Forces team
was one of the first sent
in to Northern Afghanistan
about mid-October, the same
night that Liam and his element
had evidently passed through
Colonel Dill's position,
possibly, some of them.
While that was happening with
their mission against Mullah
Omar's compound, my team was
helicoptered into the north,
into the mountains.
And the very first
morning we were there,
if you click on that photo-- as
that's playing, if you would,
on that point.
That first morning a guy named
General Abdul Rashid Dostum,
one of the Uzbek
militia commanders
that was renowned in that
region, been actively fighting
against the Taliban
and Al Qaeda.
And this was a guy that my
team was tasked to meet with.
And he come riding
up on horseback,
and that was how their
force was moving.
And so within hours six men
from my team, including myself,
mounted horses
and rode off to go
to General Dostum's
headquarters.
And for the men on my
team, although they're
highly trained Special
Forces Sergeants,
horseback riding
in the 21st century
wasn't something, even in the
Special Forces at that time,
that you typically do.
But fortunately I had
grown up on a cattle ranch
and had rodeoed
through high school.
In Kansas we have high
school rodeo teams.
CARRIE LAURENO: Just like
on the Upper East Side.
MARK NUTCH: Yeah.
But I attended college,
and while doing ROTC,
competed on the collegiate rodeo
team, actually several years.
So anyway, had this
incredible experience
to, literally at the
gallop, teach my guys
how to ride horseback
with our military gear on.
And we're riding to keep
up with the Afghans,
and it's a macho thing.
You don't want to
look like you're
an inexperienced horseback
rider with these guys.
So anyway, this started our
incredible Wild West experience
over the next several weeks
of riding horseback every day.
And the guys on my
team took to it.
We tried to walk a couple days
because we were just frustrated
with these half-trained animals.
Or if anybody rides
horses in here.
I don't know, is that
allowed at Google?
I see you have scooters
up and down the hall.
Anyway, so we rode horses
over the next several weeks
while we were doing
combat operations.
And we're calling
in close air strikes
and we're organizing this
Army that we grew out
of these different Afghan ethnic
groups of Uzbeks and Tajiks
and Hazaras, and
this melting pot
of tribes that
rallied around us.
But that American
presence gave them
hope to fight against
the Taliban and Al Qaeda.
And we learned about
their stories firsthand.
I have a very unique
experience than what
even guys in Special Forces
have experienced over the years,
as we now have armored vehicles.
And you see then that's
what everybody expects
of an American soldier right now
is body armor from head to toe.
And you're riding around
in armored vehicles.
And we didn't have armor.
We didn't take body armor.
We didn't wear it while
we were in the mountains.
CARRIE LAURENO: Why?
MARK NUTCH: Moving around.
One, it was a weight issue
of just what we were carrying
with moving everything
around by donkey
or on manned portable
loads by horseback.
And the other
thing is, honestly,
how's that look when
I'm wearing body armor,
but the guys I'm
working alongside
do not have body armor?
They have limited
ammunition, small arms.
They're wearing tennis
shoes, literally,
and the winter's coming on.
So we didn't have body armor
in there for that point.
Now later, in other
missions, after we got out
of the mountains
and we liberated
the key city of Mazar-i-Sharif
a few weeks later
and our mission focus
kind of changed,
then we would wear
some body armor.
But Special Forces does that
on some occasions for the teams
that have particular
missions where
we're trying to embed
and work with the locals.
And it's kind of hard to
establish a relationship
with people on the
street if you look
like, to them, someone
from outer space.
CARRIE LAURENO: How did Green
Berets-- how did your 12 Green
Berets, which is how Green
Berets work, in groups of 12--
build an army of 3,000 fighters
from multiple different tribes,
speaking a different
language, riding on horseback.
How did you inspire the
creation of a literal cavalry?
MARK NUTCH: As I said, the
American presence there meant
so much to them,
and that we were
willing to share hardships.
We were sharing meals with them.
We slept at the
finest Afghan hotels,
which were caves or a bunker.
You're sleeping on the ground.
You're sharing that
hardship with them.
And you're living and working,
fighting alongside them.
But we were able to meet with
these different ethnic leaders
one on one, and in some
cases, our language skills
were sufficient enough to
get across the basic points
of your conversation.
At other points we had to rely
on some Afghan interpreters,
which their English was
as bad as my Dari or Uzbek
at the time.
But the Central Intelligence
Agency had a team there,
and we worked closely with them.
And so they were able to help
facilitate some of the deeper
conversations that
needed to occur.
But as we met with
each of these four
different factional
leaders, which
had been fighting against each
other, even literally weeks
before-- but we were able to
get them to sit down and come
together in what was called an
Area Commanders' Meeting, where
it was-- think of a
three-day planning conference
in a building in a small
village in the mountains.
And we got these guys to
work together and come up
with a plan, and then how
we could support that plan.
But really, by the
actions of my Sergeants
in building that relationship
with the different commanders,
we were able to help grow
that Army and give them hope.
I don't how else
to explain that,
what a significant
thing that was
to have American servicemen
there on the ground
to help them, give them
hope that there could
be a better future
for Afghanistan.
CARRIE LAURENO: And your wife
gave birth to your youngest
child while you were doing that.
MARK NUTCH: Yes.
As I said earlier, my
wife was seven months
pregnant when I deployed.
And we were in a Babies R Us,
actually-- the wives are going
to stone me as I
tell this part--
but we were in a Babies
R Us in Nashville
when I got the phone call
about the 15th of September
that I was being
put back on my team.
And we deployed out
soon thereafter.
But my wife Amy was a
high-risk pregnancy,
and she gave birth
to our daughter Kaya.
The team wives supported
her and all that.
And by the time they
notified the chain of command
and they called me, I was
orchestrating a major offensive
that we were about to kick off
across the northern provinces.
This is about the-- she
was born on the 30th,
so this is the 31st or so.
But I got this strange
message to use the SAT phone
and to call home.
And I did, and I had a few
minutes with my wife, who
was already home
with our daughter,
and our family had come in to
help her and be around her.
I think Colonel Collins
said this earlier,
is you have to be
able to compartment.
And so had that phone call
and ended it, ended that line,
because you can't tell
them where you're at
or what you're doing.
But had a few private
minutes, and then ran off
and told Bob, my
Chief Warrant Officer
and a couple of
the other guys that
were there in that position.
But then we went right back
to planning that attack.
And we launched a major Calvary
charge literally the next day.
My daughter was four months
old before I got home,
and we just celebrated her--
I'm bad at math-- thirteenth.
CARRIE LAURENO:
Thirteenth birthday.
MARK NUTCH: In Ranger, N
is for knowledge, right?
CARRIE LAURENO:
Colonel Collins, tell
us what happens when
you're at 18,000 feet
and you decide to jump
out of an airplane.
LIAM COLLINS: Well,
people sometimes
ask, probably all of us
up here, why we jump out
of a perfectly good airplane.
It's because we know the pilots.
It's a lot safer than landing.
Yeah, so we jumped out.
It was dark.
It was really dark.
Usually you got some
ambient light out there,
but there's no ambient light
in Afghanistan in 2001.
So we jump when there
is 0% illumination.
So the moon was down.
It was dark.
And I was the youngest guy.
I mean, I'd just taken command.
I'd just finished
our HALO School,
they call it, or
Military Freefall School.
So I was--
CARRIE LAURENO: This was
your first combat tour ever.
LIAM COLLINS: Right.
So over there, and so I'm
the young guy on the team,
but I'm also the
commander of the team,
so you don't want to be
the one that screws it up.
Because then all officers
ever after you get-- wreck it
for all of them, so I
wasn't going to do that.
Luckily I didn't.
I just about hit the
guy underneath me
when-- I just about landed
on the guy underneath me.
So that part worked
out pretty well.
We ended up getting
to our position.
Two of the teams we
got to our position
where we could kind of see
the road and then call in CAS,
or Close Air Support dropped
bombs on Taliban vehicles.
One team didn't get as far
as we wanted to that night.
They put up camouflage netting.
Great thing about
camouflage netting
is it works really
well for people.
But the animals
really, apparently, we
found out early on
that they really
like it because
there's no vegetation.
So when they see movement
that means it's chow time.
So some goats that were
probably like three miles off
saw the camouflage netting and
walked right toward these guys,
and the goat herders were about
five feet from them before they
finally saw them with the
goats chewing on their SATCOM
antenna.
So despite everything,
we still felt
like we had a pretty
good position.
Those guys had to
move, but I didn't
want to be the guy who
came back and wrote a book
and had a movie about
everything that went wrong.
So we got those guys
where they had to go.
We were confident
in our abilities
and moved to a good place.
Luckily I do remember
our Fire Support officer,
who was in charge of the Close
Air Support, which was not
close at all because I don't
think it came down below 25,000
feet the whole
time we were there.
I guess the Afghanis had
some really good air defense
weapons that I never saw.
But they told us that
we'd have CAS stacked up
for days, probably like
the rest of these guys.
So once the team
got compromised,
we wanted to call
them in and bring them
on station in case
we needed them.
And sure enough, three
hours later, we finally
got somebody close.
So luckily we didn't need
them for at least three hours,
or it wouldn't have
been much good to us.
And then maybe we would have
had a book and movies and stuff.
But it worked out
pretty well for us.
Eventually we got
to our positions.
And then we were able to take
out some Taliban vehicles.
CARRIE LAURENO: Let's talk about
books and movies for a second.
There's a lot of news out
there right now about people
telling their stories, in
particular some Navy SEALs.
And I just want to hear
the reactions of people
on this panel about
what it's like to share
information and share
the stories in the way
that you're sharing
them now versus the way
that, perhaps, others
are choosing to share.
SCOTTY NEAL: So I think
we're all discussing that,
and internally you
see everybody here
being very humble about what
their accomplishments were,
because they never
think of themselves.
There's a whole lot
of "we" in this panel
right here, not a lot of "I".
And a lot of
discussion internally,
especially in the Special
Ops community and the Recon
community and everything
else, is these things
are best kept under
the radar, and it's
how we still
continue to operate.
But then there's
also a certain aspect
of why we're here and starting
to share stories, because here
we are, have never met each
other until this tour happened.
And yet we start
to realize that we
were all in the same
space at the same time
trying to achieve
the same thing.
So there's that final
mix of storytelling,
and storytelling
has been happening
since cavemen were putting
palm prints on caves.
And unless we capture
some of these aspects,
we have a whole other
generation behind us
that really don't know some of
the commitments and sacrifices
that we've made.
So it takes a leap of
faith to come in here
and just tell a bit of the story
that you're allowed to tell,
and yet highlight what you
want to tell the story about.
And that's about how we
responded, as America,
to those days here in New
York and DC and Pennsylvania.
CARRIE LAURENO: And along that
ethos of the we and not I,
there's a statue that I'd like
to show a picture of that's
down by the PATH train
near the 9/11 Memorial
that is known affectionately
as, or casually
as The Horse Soldier.
And when Mark and I were working
together on his tour and trying
to figure out what the
description should be for that
tour, we started the paragraph
with saying "Known as The Horse
Soldier..." and tell his story.
And Mark was adamant
that we should--
that he did not want
to be called The Horse
Soldier, because he led
a team of horse soldiers.
And I just need
to point that out,
because it became very clear
to me that even talking
about himself as an individual
was an uncomfortable thing,
and it wasn't an
appropriate thing for him
because of that very reason,
because they operate in teams.
Something that's been
really interesting to see
over the last 24
hours is that chapter
of history filling itself
in, and watching you all
speak to each other
and realizing you
were in the same places
at the same time,
but you never had
met each other.
And some of you have
heard of each other
but not met each other.
It seems like there are whole
chapters of history to still
be written by individuals
like yourselves
who are the actual storytellers.
What's the value in telling
your own story versus having
someone tell it for you?
SCOTTY NEAL: What was
unique is because I now
work for a nonprofit where
I get to communicate this.
So being part of an
organization [INAUDIBLE],
great storytelling usually
starts within a small group.
And then how do we tell our
own stories to each other,
and then allow others to see
that story and capture from it?
Because we were
talking about earlier,
I have so many
questions I want to ask
Mark and Liam and
everybody else.
And they're questions from
people that were there,
and I want to spend
more time engaging
where, how do we capture these
stories about ourselves, told
to each other,
edited to each other?
And that's especially
with this tour here.
And what I've found
also is that the family
becomes curious with you
in your tour as well.
And they actually learn
more than you've ever
been able to speak to them.
CARRIE LAURENO: Several of
you-- say, almost all of you--
didn't necessarily sign
up for this project
and say, yes, pick me,
I'd love to do this.
Colonel Dill, I'd love
you to share your reaction
when we first spoke.
ERIC DILL: Well, prior to
us speaking, I said no.
So it took coming around to it.
It's awkward to do
this, particularly--
so the Special Forces model
is quiet professionals.
For the Recon
community, we strive
to keep from
seeking recognition.
So we have-- we do little
things like, if you end up
in the base paper or
any type of publication,
you owe the team a
beer, or a case of beer.
And god forbid you get
your picture in there.
I won't even go there.
But so you do little
stuff like that
to teach people to not
be attention-seeking
and to be a team player.
So I was contacted by one of
the officers I respect most
in the Marine Corps,
and he mentioned this.
So with a little
persuasion, and then
thinking about what
this might mean
getting towards the
end of my career.
And I thought about
my grandfather.
I had asked him about
World War II quite a bit,
and there was some sort of
diversion or some other reason
not to talk about it.
But then when I
was in college, he
gave me a journal
that he had written.
He was in a B-24
bomber crew, and he
kept a journal of every
mission he did over Europe when
things were still pretty rough.
And I thought, well, maybe
this-- with modern technology,
this is my way to give a
journal, something lasting,
something enduring that
my kids can appreciate.
So the Tour Builder
is kind of my version
of a small journal like
what my grandfather did.
ERIC STUBNER: I'll add to
what Colonel Collins said.
I didn't have any grandfathers
in the military, anything
like that.
But you hear stories
like that of veterans
who, you know, oh, my grandpa,
he served in World War II.
He never really talked about it.
Eventually he died.
We found a box in the
garage, went through it,
stuff we don't even
know what it was.
It was just put
away after the war.
I usually don't openly come
out and push and throw.
It'll take you a
long time to find out
I'm in the military
when you meet me.
And a lot of people think
that you can ask questions.
If you ask questions, I'll talk.
I don't have a problem.
I'm just not a person
that throws it forward.
So maybe why don't you
know about your grandpa?
I don't know.
Try to talk to him,
try to ask him.
And then in addition to
it all, why you will talk
or why you'll come forward
and tell stories like this--
there are people that are
killed in action that they die.
If they die and the story's
never told, to me they die.
But if you keep them
alive by telling a story,
or do things, setting up
organizations, funds, some way
to keep alive or those
alive to keep it going,
it does inform people.
And then maybe people
will ask questions.
But ask veterans questions.
You see one, go say hi to them.
They'll love to talk to you.
JOE QUINN: Yes, Carrie.
Oops, gotta turn it on.
Yeah, just to add to that, just
listening to these stories,
sitting here listening to them.
To think why my family had
an empty place at the table
during the holidays, that these
gentlemen were out there doing
what they were doing.
So I just want to say
personally thank you,
and if everyone would
put your hands together
for everyone here.
[APPLAUSE]
So that's the reason why I
think that's the importance
of telling these stories.
And it is kind of a
Catch-22 of being humble.
But one of the
things is, as less
of a percentage of our
society has served,
it's more about meeting
civilians halfway.
And doing that halfway
is being able to try
to do the best you can to
tell about your experiences,
not only for yourself, but
for those that represent,
whether your team or your unit.
CARRIE LAURENO: Was it easy
for you to tell your story?
JOE QUINN: No.
I mean, yes, it
was very difficult.
And I've sort of been quiet
about it, especially early on,
especially the 9/11
stuff for a long time.
But to go to what
Eric was saying,
it's a great way
to remember people.
And it's fantastic that we
have technology nowadays
that helps us to keep
that memory alive
and keep my brother's
memory alive
and those that have
lost their lives.
Because I know
everyone would agree
that those are the real
heroes are the ones
that they paid the
ultimate sacrifice.
So the least we can do is kind
of tell the stories of them,
good ones, bad ones, the truth.
CARRIE LAURENO: And after
going through that experience
over the last several weeks,
and working on your own
to build these stories and
tell them in your own words,
what did it feel like to
go to the museum today
and to see perfect
strangers standing around
a bunch of kiosks reading about
your most personal professional
experiences?
Totally weird, right?
JOE QUINN: Yes.
Well, it was really weird.
Eric and I were down there, and
they were looking through it,
and they saw him in the flesh.
That was really exciting for one
of the people that were there.
That's all I really got.
CARRIE LAURENO: So
I'm sure that there
must be people here
who have questions.
We have some microphones
and some runners with mics.
Any question is a
good question here.
That's why these guys are here,
to help us understand more
about their service
and why they did it.
I hear Eric, Sergeant
Stubner next to me,
using the word chance, that
he was waiting for his chance
to deploy, and how-- you'll read
his tour and see how incredibly
disappointed he was that he
wasn't-- his team wasn't picked
to be the team to
go first, and how--
you sounded really upset
about it at the time.
And most people here don't
have those experiences.
We all have passions,
and they're all
things that we get excited
about and we want to do,
like you were saying.
But I personally want
to know, why did you
see that as an
opportunity and a chance
to go and put yourself in
such a dangerous situation?
Which is not something that
I've ever thought about doing.
Most of us run from danger, and
you saw it as an opportunity.
ERIC STUBNER: I
guess the one thing--
I found out there are quite a
few guys around that did spend
time in Ranger Regiment, too.
I'm not the only guy.
So I do have some hidden
brothers up here also.
But Ranger history,
kind of in the past,
they've been at a
lot of conflicts.
And it's usually a
short period of time.
And you do look up to those
that have gone before.
There might be-- how many
people jumped into Grenada
from Ranger Regiment?
Do you know, sir?
I don't know, you can Google it.
But there's not a whole
big group of people.
So getting to serve
in the organization
and be a part of it as a goal,
a dream, you're like, wow,
I'd love to be
one of those guys.
Before, if you would see
a guy with a combat scroll
on, you're like, wow,
he jumped into Grenada.
He jumped into Panama.
Wow.
And they are looked up to.
That was the motivation
that you had.
You wanted to do what you did.
So when it kicked off
and I was like, wow,
we're in Ready Force One,
I'm going to get to go,
they took another battalion.
It was kind of mind-blowing.
And then when we did
deploy, they only
took one company
from our battalion.
And after we went and came back,
kind of the mentality thought
was, wow, I do have my scroll.
I'm going to be one
of those select few
that gets to wear it.
Literally did I not know that
the deployments would not stop,
and eventually every Ranger
would have a combat scroll.
But it was just something
you wanted to do,
you wanted to achieve.
CARRIE LAURENO: And
despite that opportunity,
if I asked you
the question, what
do you gentlemen think about
war, how would you answer that?
SCOTTY NEAL: Basically war
is not an enduring endeavor.
It's better when it's
over very quickly.
And I think talking
to a lot of us
last night at a
dinner you hosted,
we thought the war was over.
Less than about 230
Special Operators,
a contingent of Marines, Air
Force, which isn't up here,
actually thought
that this was done.
LIAM COLLINS: I didn't
think it was over.
SCOTTY NEAL: He didn't
Well, there was a lot
of high-fiving going on
until a few months later, when
we found ourselves in Iraq.
And then now it's just been
a constant pace of life.
LIAM COLLINS: Yeah, I
mean, we live in-- I mean,
it's like a firefighter I
was equating to earlier.
I mean, a firefighter
wants to go fight a fire,
but if they're going to fight a
fire, it's kind of a bad thing
that they're leaving the
firehouse to go fight a fire.
It's the same thing, kind
of, in this line of work.
Because we train so
long and hard at it,
you kind of want to go, but
you don't really want to go,
because if you've
got to go, it's
not a good reason
that you're going.
So it'd be better if we
just kind of never went.
But if we got to go, we all come
from the mindset or whatever,
we want to be the
ones that have to do
that if somebody's got to go.
Maybe we're just all messed up
in the head, but I don't know.
MARK NUTCH: There's a
particular Bible verse
that I know as a young
officer I saw on a wall
at Ranger Regiment, which kind
of epitomizes most of probably
the guys up here--
and I can't speak
for all of them-- but the
Special Operations community.
And that's Isaiah 6:8.
"Whom shall go and
whom shall I send?
And a voice cried
out, 'Here I am.
Send me.' "
And that "Send me"
ethos is prevalent
throughout the Special
Operations community.
And I know for me
personally, although I
had a pregnant wife
and two young children,
going with my brothers and
being the first to get in there
and get some payback, and
to represent our country,
and get in there and
try and sort things out,
that is what drove us.
We recognized we were very
fortunate, and we were chosen.
It could've been
another team that
certainly could have
had that mission.
CARRIE LAURENO: Colonel
Dill, your view on war.
We talked about this last night.
I think we talked
about human beings
and was it chimpanzees,
or-- right?
ERIC DILL: Well, I'm not sure
where you wanted to go with it.
But we were talking about--
cultural anthropologist
is kind of something
I study on the side.
But the only other species
that commits murder--
I mean, animals fight, there's
dominance, things like that,
trying to establish dominance
for mates and things like that.
But the only other species that
commits murder is chimpanzees.
But I'm not sure where
you wanted to take that.
CARRIE LAURENO: You know
what, I was remembering--
I was remembering the
story and remembering
that war is a terrible thing.
And you were talking about
how you felt about war,
and how people-- no
one wants to go to war,
and that human beings--
or maybe it was Scotty.
You were talking about
that also with Scotty.
ERIC DILL: I mean,
I would say there
are human beings that
want to go to war.
And I've been around them.
And sometimes we're fortunate
that they're on our side.
But yeah, I think
there's a lot of people
that do kind of seek that.
But I think once you've
done it, you don't--
SCOTTY NEAL: I think
my quote at the end,
though, is we were
all young and we
wanted to go to
war because that's
how we saw ourselves
as young soldiers.
Now that we're old,
tired soldiers--
nobody prays for peace
more than an old soldier.
So it's hard watching
the thirteenth year
into this conflict.
And you certainly look at
some of my young pictures.
I mean, it really took
24 years off my life.
And so as this
conflict goes and goes,
part of my job when I
was a Senior Enlisted
Advisor at that
very senior level
was to remind them of
the cause of conflict
and how it's better
to get it over
quickly than to
linger this thing on.
CARRIE LAURENO: What questions
do we have from the audience?
We have microphones.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming.
My name's Matthew Lack.
Army guy, joined before
September 11, and I'm still in.
And I'm curious to get your
perspectives because you're
sort of in the same
boat I am, just
seeing how the Army was
prepared before September 11,
the lessons we had to learn
over the last 13 years
fighting two different
wars, and now
how the Army appears to be
running away from every lesson
we learned as fast
as humanly possible.
What's your general
opinion on the direction
that we're going now as an Army?
And this is my
experience in the Army--
have to count the
Marines out-- but even
as the military as a whole,
do you think there's anything
that we can do to help preserve
lessons learned so we don't
find ourselves in a
similar place 10, 20 years
from now going to war without
body armor that really was even
up to snuff?
I remember in
2003, I wasn't sure
if I was even going
to have plates
to take with me to
my first deployment.
And I'd just like to get
your thoughts on that.
ERIC DILL: Well, just quickly
from the Marine perspective--
I know he wants to hear
from the Army-- but I mean,
frankly, I'm at odds
with the institution
on where we're going.
If you look at the
potential for conflict
over the next 10 to 15
years, more than likely
it's going to be a
low-intensity conflict,
counterinsurgency-type
situation.
It's not going to be a
major conventional war,
because who would
do that right now
against the US military and
our allies and our coalitions?
But my institution's going
back towards training
for a big conventional fight.
And we call it getting back
to our roots, our amphibious
roots.
But it's not-- like I said,
I'm kind of opposed to it.
But that supports the big
military industrial complex,
big conventional wars.
And that's being a
little bit cynical,
but I feel I can be open here.
So that's probably
the reason behind it.
But we're kind of getting away.
We are, we're doing
exactly what you said.
Army?
LIAM COLLINS: Yeah,
I guess I'll go.
This is for non-attribution,
I'm assuming?
Let me give you my obligatory,
this is-- what's that?
CARRIE LAURENO: We
are being recorded.
LIAM COLLINS: All right.
I don't really-- we're
doing a much better job
than we did after
Vietnam, for sure.
SCOTTY NEAL: So as a
former Green Beret,
you wrestle with this.
And old, tired soldiers
look back and reflect.
But you know, young officers
and enlisted that come up,
there's so much information
that is stored somewhere
in some dusty building
in Kansas called
The Army Center of
Lessons Learned.
And yet we haven't
collectively learned them.
And some of those lessons-- they
don't come back to old soldiers
to relearn those lessons.
They rely on new generations,
and it takes a while
to filter out where they were.
And matter of fact, if you
look at the history of what
Ranger school was,
it was a capture
of a lesson back in
the Vietnam time.
And yet we still cling
on to that lesson.
I think that was the monkey
and the banana analogy is,
we don't know why we're
doing patrol bases--
CARRIE LAURENO: Very, very
interesting conversation
last night.
SCOTTY NEAL: But we do.
CARRIE LAURENO: Monkeys
and bananas, chimpanzees.
SCOTTY NEAL: We're
philosophical here.
Comedy troupe,
but philosophical.
ERIC STUBNER: One thing I'll say
just to add to your question.
The next conflict,
the biggest thing
I would say, where's
it going to be?
We've adapted to
clearing buildings,
driving down roads,
urban terrain.
You know, the enemies
in Spain close.
At the end of the night they
go home to their family.
You're going to their house to
knock on the door to figure out
who was the bad guy for the day.
Is it going to end up being
some jungle environment,
Vietnam again, where we're
not driving down roads?
It's hard to say with
the direction they train,
because the direction
we're going to take,
and we kind of do,
is the last conflict.
How was it?
It's going to be urban,
I believe, for awhile,
until the next major conflict
somewhat changes its route.
AUDIENCE: You guys,
I just wanted to say,
I got to K2 November 24, 2011.
So I was probably with you guys
as you were running in and out
of Afghanistan, of course.
But I was with the AC130s
as an aircraft electrician.
And it's not very often I get
to talk with the folks that
were actually running missions
in and out of Afghanistan
when we first got there.
So it's just kind of
cool to hear your stories
and hear you guys
actually talk about it.
People ask me what I did, and I
kind of joking with my friends
say, we kind of helped to throw
the spear into Afghanistan.
But you guys were
like the tip of it,
so it was kind of
cool to meet you guys
and what you guys were doing.
So thanks,
SCOTTY NEAL: And I think
what we're talking about,
you can always have
a panel of 40 people
because there were so
many different effects
between other government
agencies, other families
back home, that it is a
multi-dimensional inspiration
when at the very hardest part
that this country was facing,
all of these groups and
efforts came together and was
united in one focus point.
And it had very
dramatic effects.
And to the last
comment, you know,
as we get a little bit looser
and looser from that time
frame, we're not as unified as
we were back then supporting
each other for a focus.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm not military, but I had a
quick comment and a question
for Mark.
First of all, I do have
two great grandfathers
that actually were the first and
last Chief of the US Cavalry,
and then another
ancestor that was largely
responsible for ushering out the
horse and ushering in the tank.
So my mother was so excited
when the book "Horse Soldiers"
came out and all that, that her
grandfather would get his due,
because he was somewhat
lampooned for having said
that the horse would never,
ever be replaced by the tank.
So she's thrilled with the
re-evolution, the reappearance
of the horse in
combat environments.
My question, however,
relates to stigma.
I happen to be involved with
therapy that uses storytelling
as a device for soldiers.
But we don't see very many
special forces people there.
And it seems that
there-- you know,
the stigma for seeking mental
health support--and this is
for all of you-- is particularly
strong among Special Forces.
And I just wonder if
there are any structures
within the Special
Forces units that
often take care of their own
for those kinds of things, that
particularly address
that notion of stigma.
CARRIE LAURENO:
You're both laughing
about a very serious topic.
MARK NUTCH: Yeah, we're--
apologize for laughing,
because it's a very serious
issue about the stigma.
And I'm going to let Scotty talk
about that in just a second.
For a-- I'm going to cover
your question in a couple ways.
First, the last US
Army Calvary charge
was during World War
II in the Philippines
during the Baton
Campaign, I think in 1942.
I don't remember the
exact date, but you
can-- I almost said Bing it,
but you can Google it, right?
Sorry.
CARRIE LAURENO: That's OK.
MARK NUTCH: Anyway, to
get to your point---
CARRIE LAURENO:
Protected our freedoms.
Freedom of choice.
MARK NUTCH: No, I
want to talk just--
where am I going
to go with this?
My particular team of 12
guys has continued to serve.
We've been through all this,
had senior sergeants from Desert
Storm from this,
and the Gulf War.
They've spent their entire
career in Special Forces
and deployed
throughout the Middle
East and various
other hot spots.
But every one of
those guys stayed in.
Two of us left active
service, but then have
continued to deploy repeatedly.
Those sergeants that
got out and retired
after they went back to Iraq,
five, six more deployments.
They, even after
retiring, have continued
to work as instructors to try
and help pass on that knowledge
within our community
in some way,
were continuing to get on with
their life to try and continue
to contribute in different ways,
as are all the other veterans.
But 9/11 defined our
lives in our community.
And we are looking to
find ways to transition.
I'm going to let Scott
handle the stigma, I guess.
But what I want to say is,
we feel normal, I guess.
I don't feel like I have or
need to seek medical attention
and counseling
for me personally.
And yes, we saw a lot of
traumatic things on my team,
specifically with our
personal experience.
But there are veterans out
there that do need assistance,
and there was that stigma.
I know they've worked
hard to change that.
A mutual friend of Sergeant
Stubner's and I, Nate Self,
was a Ranger captain
that was one of the first
to kind of start to speak
about this thing called
post traumatic stress as
a Ranger officer, infantry
officer, to then to
start to address that.
And his book's called "Two
Wars," where it talks about not
just about the battle you
had with your teammates,
but then that battle coming
back home to transition.
SCOTTY NEAL: Oh, thank you.
MARK NUTCH: Yeah, thank you.
SCOTTY NEAL: So now there seems
to be a lot of conversation
lately about why aren't
people opening up,
yet you heard about our
grandfathers and everything
else that packed it away.
And I personally
use that analogy
in the movie "Ghostbusters" when
they would suck in the demon,
and they would go to
the big wall grid,
and they would pump it in there.
And there's a very
dramatic scene
where they're
begging the person,
don't open up that wall.
But we have coping mechanisms
that are different.
And I remind a lot of people
that Special Operations
and Special Forces are highly
trained and highly selected.
And those one character
traits are actually
brought out during
our selection course.
So the way to start engaging
and getting people to open up
is through leadership of exactly
what we're doing here, OK?
Starting on the edges,
telling the story.
And remember, this
is a trusted network,
and to think a health
professional can
come in instantly and you
will trust them with something
that you were trying to put
a little bit further down
is difficult.
So what I tend to say to others
that, instead of spending
years upon years getting a
health professional to be
trusted, why don't
we just equip those
that are trusted
to be better peers?
CARRIE LAURENO: Other questions?
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
First I just want to
say that I couldn't
be more proud as an American
and as a New Yorker to know
that all of you were
there to defend us
after the events of 9/11.
So thank you very much.
This is kind of directed
to Scott and to Mark,
but they referred
to Special Forces
as the quiet professionals.
And in a world where
everyone is quick
to dramatize or romanticize
our war fighters as just that,
as fighters, can you
talk a little bit
about what it means to
be a quiet professional,
and maybe how you're
trained to avoid conflict
in many situations,
avoid fighting and harm
to the locals whose
environment you come into?
SCOTTY NEAL: So for anybody
who doesn't know John,
John works for UBS and has
very quietly and patiently
helped the Green Beret
Foundation, especially
Mark, led to that statue you
see in the background, which
led to the larger
one at Ground Zero.
And what he's getting
at is, we can hardly
tell our stories to ourselves.
Yet through our engagement,
strategically a lot of people
have come around
to help us engage.
If a Green Beret and
Special Forces particularly,
we are not the sharpest
tool in the toolbox.
We're very clever tools,
and at any one time
we're deployed between
50 to 55 countries
in small elements,
usually 12-man team.
And we're on the very
edges of stability.
We're on the very
edges of diplomacy.
In one of those pictures
in there I wore a suit.
So a good Special Forces
soldier are on the other edges
before they boil
up into conflicts.
And it's funny, at the
very end of my time
before I retired in 2010,
I helped start a program.
And I had a very
minor part, but it
was called Village Stability
Operations, which actually
put Green Berets and SEALS
back into the villagers,
treating them dentistry,
local medicine, all
of these other things
that would deliver
some of these social services.
And they weren't the tools of
black helicopters and night
vision.
LIAM COLLINS: Yeah,
I'll answer the part
about the quiet professional.
I think every organization
has a culture.
I mean, Google's got a culture.
So I think, why is
it so important to be
a quiet professional for
something like-- especially
in Special Forces, which
has 12-person detachment.
Ranger Regiment's a
little larger platoons,
their companies that
they're operating under.
But fundamentally you've got
to trust the person that's
next to you, because
your life is on the line
with them all the time.
And if it's something
that-- someone's out
for their own personal gain,
then you can't trust them.
And then if you
can't trust them,
that's-- instead of
being down to 11 people,
you're really down to 10,
because now you've got to have
somebody watch the person
that you can't trust.
So I think it really
comes down to that.
And yeah, there's always going
to be some that go out there,
and I guess write and
do stuff after that.
But there's been no real
book or movie written
about getting Saddam
Hussein, and that's
the way it should be for
these kind of things.
That's all I'll say.
CARRIE LAURENO: Any
other questions?
AUDIENCE: First
of all, thank you
for-- I don't know
if this is on.
It's on, OK.
Thank you for coming.
We're just honored
to have you here.
I'm curious.
What's the most useful
thing that any of you
have ever seen a civilian do
in terms of helping people,
service members when they come
back, whether they're still
active in the military
or when they're exiting?
Is there anything in particular
that you would say about
that you could tell us?
JOE QUINN: Yeah.
I would say just show up.
You know, tomorrow's
going to be Veterans Day,
and we're going to be--
the Google Analytics,
the word veteran's
going to spike high,
and then it's going to come
right down the next day.
So to me, it's just show up.
I'm part of a veteran
organization called Team Red,
White & Blue.
And to go back what Colonel
Einsenhower's saying,
veterans returning
to communities,
not returning to the Pentagon.
And they're going to
be in your communities,
and they're not going
to be wearing this.
They might not be
wearing a suit, either.
But they're in your communities.
And for me, the
most important thing
is just showing up and
introducing yourself,
and getting to
actually know a veteran
beyond just the thank you.
SCOTTY NEAL: I want
to add to that, too,
and I hate to dominate the
microphone, but-- anyways.
Just like Special
Forces and Recon,
we are the military scouts.
We go into these very ambiguous
areas and we map it out.
We get an understanding of
the language and the culture
and the sensitivities,
all these things
that intelligence from
afar can't tell you.
And it's the same
thing in communities.
So beyond that, how
do you take a veteran
and you show that
amount of patience,
and you show them business
cultures, work cultures,
how to start a business, all of
these simple mentoring things.
Because once they're upright
in a community, they excel.
And I tell everybody, every
mission's a business plan.
The truth of why we're selected
and we had successful careers
are the same characters that
a lot of these companies
seem to be starving
for, everyone I engage.
So if you just take that
patience and that little bit
of remolding, and understand
the transition phases
that a person goes through,
then what you get out
of that is you get somebody
that's re-centered and oriented
and just loyal 'til
the day is long.
And they become good
citizens and employees back
in the community.
CARRIE LAURENO: Any
final questions?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I have one quick question.
Thank you so much
for being here.
I lost my cousin after
2001 in Afghanistan,
and just hearing these stories
is so amazing and touching.
My question is, in
2007 and leading
into 2008 when the
sentiment at home
really started to
turn against the war,
when Rumsfeld was
replaced and-- how
did that feel internally for
you guys in the military?
Was it something that the
waves of political sentiment
come and go, and
this is your job
and you just go
and do your duty?
Or did you really
start to feel it?
Did it feel like how we hear
about Vietnam vets coming home
and they don't get the parades?
Did it feel like
that, or did it not?
LIAM COLLINS: I mean, for me
it didn't really impact it.
I was actually surprised
that the wave probably
stayed as long as it did.
I expected it to kind
of go down a lot sooner.
Because we just--
I mean, in America
we don't have the
patience for a long war.
It's just, we're worried
about quarterly earnings, not
long-term growth.
So I expected it to die down
a lot sooner than it did.
So it didn't really
impact me, but I'm
sure others might have
a different opinion.
SCOTTY NEAL: So once
again, you know,
it's interesting that I went
from the tactical aspects
of being on the ground, deployed
five to six times continuously,
usually two months at a time.
And you're not aware
of the politics side.
That's what's unique about
soldiers is we really don't get
into policy, politics,
and public perception,
the three bad P's.
But then when I went to the
strategic headquarters and I
started realizing
that they really
are what shapes
America's military
and how it looks at
fighting this war,
restricting resources.
And I saw the fight
at a different level,
from the distance of
Washington to manage
the public perception.
Yet the soldiers,
once again, were still
motivated about that day, 9/11,
and what they're going for.
And if you still
look at it, you know,
the recruitment was still high.
There were still youth
joining the military.
They still believed in
the cause of their fight.
What had shifted was how we
were going to maintain that.
And now we had a
different magnet,
and that magnet was the
politics and the public pressure
that kind of started
to bend things.
CARRIE LAURENO: Any
final questions?
SCOTTY NEAL: First I want
to thank Carrie, by the way.
We first met-- we had a little
event at the National 9/11
Museum as a way for us to put
closure to the effects of war
and started talking
about our own transition.
And Carrie came there a
little bit patient at first.
But she has really been a
tiger in the veterans' space
and wants to know how Google can
help, because they have tools
and they have a brand that
everybody admires and loves.
And we began working
very closely after that.
And really every
day she has worked
very hard, along with everybody
else that you probably
don't see behind the scenes, in
understanding the National 9/11
Museum, and
understanding New York
City and its feelings
for that very day,
that this really is
truly monumental.
And if I were in
this organization,
I would learn how
initiatives begin
and how they come
together at the end.
And that needs to be studied
as well, because it really
was a drive and a vision
that finally became reality
by this panel today.
CARRIE LAURENO:
Thank you, Scotty.
[APPLAUSE]
I say this a lot,
and I really mean it,
that the inspiration
is so strong
that it makes it easy
for me to do my job.
I know so many service members
and count them as friends,
you among them at this point.
And it's easy to
see why I love what
I do when there are incredible
stories like those on the stage
that you all have been sharing.
I want to make one
final comment, which
is many of these gentlemen have
their family members here today
in this audience.
And while we talk a lot
about the heroism that
happens in the military, and
the type of personality that
is able to sustain all
kinds of serious danger,
there are people
who are at home who
are taking care
of these families
and making sure that these men
have a life to come home to.
The burden on the family
is absolutely enormous.
Mark shared among
the most difficult,
and so did several
other people here.
There are tremendous sacrifices
on a personal basis that
are made so that
when there is a need,
there are people in this country
who are willing to go and put
themselves in harm's way so that
the rest of us don't have to.
And I just-- I really
want to take a moment
to recognize those women
who are here who held down
those families and took
care of those children
and made sure that the family
unit survived and sustained
these individuals to go in
and do the types of things
that they did.
So if we could-- I'm going
to ask you all to stand up.
Please do, because
it's your day, too.
[APPLAUSE]
CARRIE LAURENO: Thank you.
And with that, I'd like to
call up Colonel Eisenhower,
and we can stay up here.
Colonel James Eisenhower
is a special assistant
to the Chairman of the
Joint Chiefs of Staff.
He commands the Office
of Reintegration,
and Colonel Eisenhower is a
tremendous partner and friend
of ours here at Google.
His office is tasked
with facilitating
inter-service communication,
fostering community solutions
to the challenges facing
veterans and military families,
and to further civilian
military understanding, which
is what this panel
was all about today.
Colonel Eisenhower.
JAMES EISENHOWER: Thanks.
Thanks for the
opportunity to talk.
Happy birthday to the
Marines, 239 years.
And 69 years ago today
also was very important,
because Army beat Notre
Dame 48 to nothing
and were the national champions.
So that's where I live.
I wanted to stand back
here and thank Carrie,
because this is what I
know of Liam Collins.
It's the back view.
She said Liam can run
a mile in six minutes.
No, Liam can run two
miles in about 9:20.
LIAM COLLINS: Slower.
JAMES EISENHOWER: Slower.
A little slower?
9:40?
And we were classmates
at West Point,
and I only knew the
back view of Liam,
because when you run
the APFT at West Point,
you do it in groups
of, like, 20.
And there's 4,000 cadets there.
And you do it over
the course of days.
And I kept getting
put in Liam's group,
and he would run in, like, 9:20.
And by the time I finished--
I was passing, but by the time
I finished he was showered and
had a pizza out and was dining.
And so this guy's
six minutes is what
he runs when I'm on his back.
Carrie, thanks very much for
asking us to come up here
and for putting this on.
And thanks to Google.
Thanks to all of you
for your contribution
to the common defense.
You probably want to know
why I'm saying that now,
and I'll be really
quick with you.
The chairman, General
Dempsey, for whom I work,
has no statutory obligation
when it comes to service members
after they leave the service.
Neither does DOD.
But he says we've got
a moral obligation
to take care of these men
and women who've served.
So he's put our office together.
We've got several lieutenant
colonels and a colonel.
And we in the Chairman's
Office of Reintegration
try to go out and
understand where
there are fantastic examples
of effective reintegration
mechanisms.
And we take that
and we share it.
We're really just
a knowledge broker.
We're not bringing
anybody money,
and we're not bringing
anybody manpower.
But let me tell you why
I think that's important.
Reintegration's hard.
And we had a great
question over here,
what's the most important
or significant thing
that civilians have done?
And I would submit to you,
answering the question,
is that it's more
than just a handshake.
You'll hear the chairman say
often, we don't need a handout,
we need a handshake.
I'd ask you to follow it up
with just a brief conversation.
It's a dialogue.
Why?
Because all we know for
the duration of our service
is the military culture.
Most of us entered right out
of high school or right out
of college.
We know nothing else when
it comes to our adult life.
And military culture
is necessarily
very different than
the civilian community,
because at the end of the day we
must be effective war fighters.
That culture will
always be different.
You are masters of
the civilian community
because you live
and thrive there.
Believe it or not, it's
intimidating to us.
We are far more comfortable
going in from 18,000 feet
into Afghanistan, or getting
on the back of a striker
and riding into downtown Baghdad
in the middle of the surge,
than we would be to try to
navigate the civilian landscape
here in New York
City and find a job.
We're not good at it.
You know it, and you can
help us manage that process
by simply giving us advice.
Ask us how we're doing.
If we need any advice based
off of your own expertise,
say, look, I've been here at
Google for this many years.
I've been here in New
York City for five years.
Do you have a dentist?
Do you have a church?
Where do you think
you want to work?
What are you
thinking about doing?
If you can help us
navigate the landscape,
you help us become
much more successful,
and we will become
the civic assets
that you've already
heard veterans typically
tend to become.
The chairman published
an Op Ed a year
and a half ago, and it
was a shot across the bow
to everyone in uniform.
When we talk about the
civil military divide,
most people say,
well, the civilians
need to understand more
about the military.
And you all have done a
wonderful job of allowing us
a platform where we
can share with you some
of the characteristics
and things that
make military culture different,
and that professional ethos
unique and distinct.
But the chairman said to
those who are in uniform,
we need to understand more
about the civilian community.
So that's where I'd
ask you to come in.
Help us.
Extend the hand, but
follow that handshake
with a short discussion
or a short dialogue that
helps us navigate this
difficult terrain.
That will make all the
difference in the world.
And here's why.
The target for us is the
dinnertime conversation
that's going to
happen in 10 years
when a young lady asks
her mom or dad which
service she should join.
We don't want it to be,
should I join the service,
but which service should I join?
And the counsel she's going
to get from her parents,
and from her priest, and from
her soccer coach and counselor,
is going to be shaped by the
success with which we embrace
veterans today here in New York
City and across the country.
And if they see our society
embrace veterans and recognize
them for the civic assets
we know they can become,
then you're going to preserve
the all-volunteer force.
And you're going to encourage
those kids, the youth of today,
to raise their hand and take
an oath to support and defend
the Constitution of
the United States.
That's your contribution
to the common defense.
So on behalf of General Dempsey,
the Chairman of the Joint
Chiefs of Staff, thanks
for your contribution
to the common defense today.
And I'd hope you take
this example that Google
has set for the rest
of us and propagate it
across our country, and try to
embrace veterans and understand
more about them.
But help us understand more
about the civilian community
to which we will return.
Thanks very much.
CARRIE LAURENO: With that, I'd
love to wish a happy Veterans
Day to all of our service
members who are here
today to thank you
for your service.
And thank you to you gentlemen
for sharing your most
personal stories
with us in an effort
to make this community here at
Google-- and everyone watching
this video online,
eventually-- aware of the fact
that in their community there
are veterans there as well.
I love the idea of
following up a handshake
with a conversation.
We try to do that here.
We care deeply about supporting
the transition of our veterans
and our military
families and will
continue to do so for
a long time to come.
Thank you, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]